Mark you can help me get a phone could
you I got a phone for you right here
thanks I stock up for you thank
you sorry it's just kind of been a bit
of a long week I don't
know Rebecca tell me what's going on I
don't know just been around I don't
know you're were kind of depressed
earlier this morning yeah I was just
kind of having a bit of a weird morning
I know kind of stay out I don't know
something happened though I don't know I
was just kind of stressed honestly I'm
just trying to get back out there I
guess kind of I don't
know you in the hospital yeah I was in
the hospital for a bit I was just kind
of feeling a bit bad I don't know a bit
bad
yeah can you be a little more
descriptive I know I just kind of a
little a little that I know it's kind of
a little messed up I don't
know well you're always a little messed
up yeah some that I so that means you
must have been especially messed up I
guess I don't
know kind of try to make it better I
don't
know TR
to there is no try I know
there's do do
do are you glad Summer's back huh are
you glad Summer's back I guess yeah not
so cold on the street yeah I love
summer had any fun
lately trying to I don't know what's
what's fun for you just being
out and know like being around people do
people recognize you on the street yeah
from my videos yeah they're really good
to me mhm it got it got better lately
everybody loves you almost everybody I
don't know I hope
so I think a lot of us would love to see
you get better but you have to you have
to want that I do no you don't you want
it right now but tomorrow will be a
different story H
yeah I want to do
it
better do when you can convince me that
you're serious I am I am I'm really am
give me 4 days in a row where you're
telling me that and then we'll we'll do
it enough come back tomorrow in the next
day and the next day and convince me
that you're on the right that you want
that I do that's today I'm just ready
to make it back I don't know make a I
don't
know today Saturday so let's let's let's
do this every day for a few days and
then we'll okay that's kind of going to
go to Hollywood maybe
but you said you wanted to shower in a
shave
yeah I can I can send you across the
street that would help thanks
okay thanks Mark sounds
good I just like what did I do did I do
something wrong or no you did nothing
wrong you're fine oh my God like like oh
my go can I just like can I make it
n so I wasn't
like
what what's what's going on Rebecca I
don't know I just feel like you don't
feel you don't seem good
today how do you how do you mean
like huh
h
Huh
huh
h
I'm starting to lose hope for you what
do you
mean you just seem to be getting worse
and worse every time I see you but I
don't know I feel like sometimes
I'm I mean I'm very capable I
just I don't know why
like I know I hit a button but I know I
can
huh
H is there anything I can do for you
what do you mean is there anything I can
do for you I don't know I just I want to
go to Hollywood and
I what do you mean
like
huh
huh I don't know
said I think the drugs are just a little
bit too out of control right
now
huh
huh um
oh my goodness wait did I just no I
don't want to but what did I just no
please I don't want to did I just
huh
what I don't know what to do with you
what do you
mean I don't know what to do for
you one
too you know she's
weird just happened
like huh wait
which wait
what
oh wait no no
way
ready for the
[Music]
sun kind like
h h
what
happen
What
huh
what
she's like I know she's
like
huh what the [__] happening
here huh wait what
huh M what's wrong wait
what um you're fidgety I guess
yeah
what you
mean what how I
just I'm mean offer to the devil on
behalf of the Rothchild family is that
okay with you
good
anyway stretch it down a little bit I
know
right I wish to be eaten up and have my
thing hard on a play Team fix
this
got
wet let's get wet
[__] go it's hot today let's got wet
[__] so hot you're so
hot you're in a better mood today you're
in a better mood today you look [__]
today you look really
depressed you look miserable what's
wrong with you L up [__] people are
dying balls now what's going on outside
[__] bored as [__] there's a protest
what are they protesting four women have
chained themselves to the walls of the
Supreme
Court and the steps are covered in blood
abortion anyway it's very beautiful and
poetic and cohesive very um abortion
well abortion yeah but you know Marina
brovich well not abortion of Marina
brovich but you know the blood mainly
your blood is what is your blood mean to
you what does your blood mean to you
what does your blood mean to you keeps
me alive oh that's that that's it you
don't like how it looks yeah it's
cool okay ask me a
question I don't even know what to ask
you anymore give me something to ask
give me something to [__] work with I
don't I don't know what you're asking me
give me you came to me you came to me do
you just come to me for the money of
course not well you just you don't talk
to
me I don't know you just have me to give
me money no no you said you're spiraling
downward and I don't know what to talk
about I'm not spiraling down downward
and all you're doing is giving me
$40 but I don't disrespect you in anyway
I love you and thank
you why don't you spend time with me
don't you love me I have a hard time
spending time with you when you're like
the mood you were in yesterday well
that's not my fault it's yours you put
me in it you're spirling me down it's
cuz I'm giving you money no it's not
it's cuz you're only giving me $40 and
you're giving them hundreds of
you love them more than me but I accept
I'm afraid of giving you more cuz you
think you'll kill
yourself I'll kill you no I won't but
I've already done
it I'm so dead
inside Reagan High
School next go I'm having fun today next
question Mr
D how do you how do you become so so
culturally I don't I'm [__] you no
you're very tuned into music and movies
and all kinds of stuff I just am but you
you don't have any money you live on the
street I don't even have a
phone I give you a phone how long does
it last a day not um it gets stolen I'm
skinny I'm a skinny get on skid R it
dies it's a phone they go to this woman
she's a friend of mine her name is uh
you can call her uh let's call her o she
takes my phones through the glass and
turns them into snakes
and Malice and sassa
fros and she is my own and I am her all
and she takes my phone and makes it her
ball and plays a game of chittery talk
for I'm her cat and she is my tat tot
tot tip for top mark But offer than me
next you're in an interesting mood today
ver ver if you could have anything right
now what would you what would you want
Mar and Ashley Olson Versace dress schow
bag fur Co Grandma Molly Ken Roy copy of
fashion book apartment Rave um million
dollars uh Harry Winston thick Diamond
like maybe Bengals or sleeves and
Diamond Girls Girls and Madonna Madonna
Madonna Madonna Madonna Madonna Madonna
Madonna what would you have Mark what
would you
want I'd like to see you get your life
together but I don't think you then get
it together stop [__] eting excuse me
no it's not up to me you're why you why
you putting it on me stop putting it on
me help me or don't you're giving me $40
giving them you're giving them hundreds
why you putting the [__] on me huh no
real [__] Mark everybody every time no
no no Mark listen to me all the money
that I give people get gets spent on
drugs no well good for them Mark every
time I see you you give me way less than
them they spend it on [__] Croc what
do I do no but I'm not I'm giving you
money no no no I spend it on my uh
huh I'm giving you money every day
though you don't give me money every day
you give me money once a week give me
money once every two weeks not that I'm
not thankful as [__] for it because I
love you for it I love you so much and
thank you and it's not about the money
Mark but they don't [__] know you I'd
love to get to know you you don't want
to get to know me that's fine I don't
[__] care about your money but I do
need it to survive and you give them
hundreds and you give me 40 and that's
fine but I gave you money yesterday and
the day before that and the day before
that and you spend money every day and
that what you got at Starbucks
today hm what' you get at Starbucks I
don't go Starbucks where do you go I
don't go anywhere me neither I don't
drink coffee I don't go anywhere I have
no
friends
vers
Versace Versace tell me about your dress
huh tell me about your dress huh Versace
aquamarine Venus I don't
know where'd you find it I found it I
found it in like um it's like an abandon
kind of a field behind the gate and they
were like PS of cloes it's I just found
it there by like Louis Vuitton wallet
and like there was like a little garger
snake and this beautiful F coat so so
many people write me and they say they
want to donate their their clothing give
them to me stop making excuses but
you're but you're not going to here's
what you would do what would I do you
don't know me [__] stop putting your
[__] on me what would I do you don't
know me I know you very well no you
don't know me very well you don't know
me at all you don't spend time with me
you don't know me don't interrupt me
I've given you 40 60 bucks on the street
and I spend it on food what do you do
with your money no no you walk away from
it you leave it on the sidewalk no I
don't you're insane are you crazy are
you crazy I've seen you do this are you
crazy I don't do things more than
once of course I leave his offerings to
who I give you a phone I leave him his
offerings to the devil man you lose the
phone I leave them as offerings to the
devil he needs money he needs phone how
many phones have I given you four you
lost all four of them within yes I left
them to the devil I love him okay I have
a crush on him and I want to give him
phones and money cuz I love him he's
beautiful beautiful Mark
beautiful anyway I leave his offerings
to the Devil Hill Satan offering to the
devil good friend you know great guy
hoping one day he will come and take me
away to promise I never been in prom so
I was going to go to prom with devil
anyway so you know I leave little gift
he's a great guy but you it's kind of
you know ain't got nothing God
however you're out there honey my name
is Rebecca and I have a really big crush
on you after you're getting the phones
and the care packages and the money so
yeah anyway next what are you doing for
the devil Mark he does everything for
you he made you that camera he made you
that phone what are you doing for the
devil what do you think of the devil
Mark he's got a good hold on you what do
you think of the devil what do you think
of him what does the devil mean to
you
all right I'm going to give you your 40
bucks let you no you're going to give me
100 kill yourself you're going to give
me 100 I won't kill myself I need money
for what for food and water people
survive on money people need money to
eat Mark they're all family people need
money to
eat food costs money Mark no seriously
Mark I spend hours a day running the
streets through the dumpster ow my feet
are killing
me [__] you Mark I love you you don't
spend my money on food yeah I spend your
money on food you're a very sexy doggy
you're my sexy little golden tree AR you
don't spend a dime of the money right of
course I
do you how much food cost these days
stop it $1 million stop it you spend it
all on drugs models never
eat
ver
also I didn't like your boyfriend anyway
anyway exactly Mar don't
eat scalped can you rub my feet oh I
have
stigato I have stigato like Patricia are
cat it all goes to the devil I love it
more than
anything even God
itself also if you're out there am can't
I Olson hello my name is
Rebecca and I love you and I'm here to
offer myself to you a sacrifice to the
devil I worship at your feet Mary K
Ashley Olson you are my god and
goddesses thank you for your time my
name is Rebecca
olon and I love
you going really bored buying I have a
tumor in my
ear bye [__] always
okay